olivia rodrigo was just spotted cozying
up to a new guy
it was so good the driver's license
singer was snapped kissing film producer
adam faze over the weekend
in los angeles that's the 18 year old
puckered up with
24 year old adam resting against an audi
olivia rocking a loose braid a casual
t-shirt and brown pants
adam in jeans and a white t-shirt we're
so stoked
so just who is olivia's new guy adam is
the co-founder of production company
must be nice and worked as a contributor
for forbes in 2017 when he was 20 years
old
and if you were thinking about doing a
deep dive on his social media to learn
more
think again both his twitter and
instagram accounts are private
but they both follow each other on insta
the two first sparked romance rumors
when they attended the space jam
a new legacy premiere party at six flags
magic mountain together
last month as for olivia's past
the singer was previously linked to her
high school musical the musical the
series co-star joshua bassett
olivia's amazing and her breakup anthem
phil
debut album sour is widely thought to be
about their split
that's pretty crazy and a rumored love
triangle between
olivia joshua and his alleged new
leading lady
sabrina carpenter so when you're gonna
tell her that we
did that too she thinks it's special
but when et sat down with josh in march
he said he was laughing off
all the headlines i think the small the
songs speak for themselves
that's really the truth like if you
listen to him like that's the
inspiration for it you know um
but yeah it's funny just for me to see
people like
speculate or make theories about things
like i don't see a lot of it but
what i see i'm like where are you
getting this
from like what it's so funny how people
like pieces together but
you know i get it we're all in
quarantine everybody's got nothing to do
so everyone's trying to
make more meaning out of something than
there is
[Music]
as for the rumors that his track lie lie
lie was a rebuttal to driver's license
[Music]
[Applause]
well he had this to say plain and simple
it's just not
and when et chatted with josh and olivia
together in 2020
they had nothing but praise for each
other as creatives
a big reason that i grew so much is
because i met joshua who is obviously
this
amazing musician singer-songwriter and i
think
before that i had never really met
anyone that was kind of interested in
the same things that i was interested in
that was like my age
and that was really inspiring and i
think he really pushes me
to do better i think one of the things
that i've really learned from
olivia is the um the storytelling aspect
of songwriting and i think she really
does a job of like
telling a story and putting you in that
time and place and i think that
that's been super um inspiring to me and
has definitely influenced
my music but i definitely think that we
we kind of grow from each other